-Welcome back.
It's been anything
but a silent night here
on "Password."
Sam has won our game
and now has a chance to play
with both Jimmy and Megan
to win $25,000.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Sam, I'm so excited for you.
So what are you going to do when
you win this $25,000.
-Period.
-I have such a passion
for making a positive impact
on kids,
my own children, my students
and my summer campers.
I want most of that money
to go towards them,
to let them become
their very best selves.
I would love that.
-Alright, that's fantastic.
-I love that.
-Well, here is.
how the bonus round works.
We're going to give you
10 passwords
beginning with the letter N
and continuing through
each letter to the letter W.
You will be the clue giver
and start
by choosing one celebrity
to be the guesser.
Then we'll take a break
and the other celebrity
will take over to guess
the remaining
passwords in 30 seconds.
If you sweep the board
and you get all 10,
we'll send you home
with $25,000.
-$25,000.
-Now, which celebrity would you
like to play with first?
-Meghan Trainor.
-Let's go, guys.
-Let's go.
-You got this.
You're lucky.
-You're lucky you got Meg.
-Alright,
30 seconds on the clock.
Only Sam can pass.
And if you can't think of an
answer, just say the word clue,
Meghan, and he'll
give you another clue, alright?
Alright, you got this.
On your marks, get set, go.
-Smell.
-Nose.
-Close.
-Off.
-On.
-Pass if you need to.
-Pass.
Win.
-Prize.
-King.
-Queen.
-Fix.
-Clue.
-Despair.
-Glue.
-Fix.
-Okay.
-Pass, pass.
-Uh, turkey.
-Sausage.
-Ham. Lunch.
-Uh, sandwich.
-Nashville.
-Tennessee.
-Whoa!
-That wasn't bad at all.
-Not bad.
I said I think we got this.
-Yo, that was everything.
Yo, yo.
-Yo.
-Yo, yo.
Last time I got, like, one.
-Yo, that's us, baby.
-That was pretty amazing.
You got five correct
for a total of $5,000.
That's literally
just half of the password.
-Halfway there.
-Okay?
-But of course,
we're going to try
and get you that $25,000.
You did amazing, Meghan.
Jimmy, you're up next.
-For the kids, for the kids.
-For the kids.
-Anything for the kids.
-You got it Jimmy.
-Love your, brother.
-Let's go.
-I'm so proud of myself.
-Okay, you've got
five remaining passwords.
U, V, W
and back to the O and R.
You could be 30 seconds away
from a $25,000 payment.
Alright?
-You got this, come on.
-30 seconds on the clock.
-Come on, Jimmy.
On your mark, get set,
take it all home.
-Over.
-Under.
-Purple.
-Uh, uh, violet, violet.
-Summer.
-Winter.
-Close.
-Clue. Outerwear.
-Shut.
-Open.
-Fix.
-Repair.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on now!
-You got all 10 passwords.
Congratulations to Sam.
He just won $25,000.